a Song of Ice and Fire is a huge
complicated story with literally
thousands of characters 22 of whom and
named John so it's fair enough that the
show Game of Thrones had to simplify
things a bit by cutting and combining
many characters it's a shame though
because many of even the minor
characters have heaps of really cool
backstories and connections and layers
to them that add a lot to the series a
good example is Thoris of mere we know
him in the show as a member of the
Brotherhood without banners the outlaw
group who captured I again dree and hot
pie in season 3 the leader of the
Brotherhood
beric Dondarrion is killed but hound but
then Thoris resurrects beric using the
power of the red god were law which may
foreshadow a certain other red priest
resurrecting a certain Jon Snow not to
name any names but anyway that's
basically foresters role in the show so
far
but in the books there's more to his
story Thoris was born in the city of
Muir he was the youngest of eight
children so his father gave him to a
temple of real or where Thoris was
trained to be a red priest he prayed the
prayers and spoke the spells and did
sometimes see visions in flames but he
wasn't much of a believer being more
interested in food and women eventually
he was sent to Westeros to convert King
Aerys Targaryen to the faith of the red
God the temple figured that since mad
errors infamously loved fire he might
like the Lord of Light but Thoris failed
to convert Harris when Aerys was
overthrown Thoris became bruised with
the new King Robert Baratheon
they were peas in a pod both gluttons
and salts who loved eating and drinking
and whoring and fighting Thoris would
fight in tournaments with his sword
alight with wildfire and he fought in
the graduate abelian setting iron man
afire with every slash of his flaming
sword so he sounds like quite the
warrior but in the same way that Bobby B
is a pretty shitty King Thoros is a
pretty shitty priest Tywin calls him a
fat jape & Gondry's Master toboe who
sells Thoris the swords he sets a fire
calls him a fraud and as bad a priest as
there ever was Thoris apparently gives
up on trying to convert anyone and he
doesn't seem to even believe in ruler
anymore but all that changes in the war
of the five kings in book 1 the mountain
Gregor Clegane starts brutally raiding
in the Riverlands so Ned Stark acting on
behalf of King Robert orders a group of
men to go stop him the group is led by
Lord beric Dondarrion and includes about
a hundred men including Thoreau's so the
men go after the mountain but at the
mummer's Ford they're ambushed the whole
thing was a trap designed by Tywin
Lannister to get Ned the only reason it
didn't work was because Ned couldn't
come because Jaime injured his leg so
anyway the group is smashed by the
mountains men some of the managed to
escape and regroup but beric is mortally
wounded with a lance from through his
chest
Thoros distraught her for his dying
friend performs a death right of the red
priests called the last kiss breathing
fire into Barracks body to thaw Rose's
shock the dead man shudders his eyes
come open and beric is brought back to
life this causes a religious real
wakening the Thoreau's he says the Lord
of Light has woken in his heart as the
remnants of barracks man regroup Thoros
converts them to his rediscovered faith
binding them together as a holy
Brotherhood sworn to serve their realm
their God and each other even after King
Robert dies the Brotherhood fights on in
his name protecting the common people
from the ravages of Raiders like Gregor
they fight a guerrilla war against the
Lannisters in the river land striking
suddenly then vanishing back into the
woods
Thoros fights in these battles with his
flaming sword he sees visions in his
flames of the future present and past
and he resurrects beric five more times
as he keeps dying in his fights the
Thoris is convinced that he's an
instrument of God he's finally doing
something with his life that he believes
in and it changes him when IO first sees
Thoris with the Brotherhood she hardly
believes it's him she remembers the red
priest as fat with a smooth face and a
shiny bald head but now Thoris has a
droopy face and a head full of shaggy
gray hair Thoreau says that a year in
the wild has melted the flesh of him
that he is less than he was but more
this change in appearance mirrors the
change
his character from glutton and a sort a
fat joke of a priest to a man filled
with righteous purpose and faith but his
story doesn't end there
in the last Brienne chapter of feast we
hear that beric Dondarrion has died a
final time giving his flame of life to
the dead Catelyn Stark who rises as Lady
Stoneheart Stoneheart
is totally different to what Catelyn was
like alive she's vengeful hateful
completely without mercy and as the new
leader of the Brotherhood she begins a
brutal campaign killing everyone who's
in any way connected to the red wedding
even people who weren't really
responsible like Peter and Merritt Frey
she even hangs Podrick though pod is
apparently still alive so don't worry
but the point is that under stone heart
the Brotherhood does some [ __ ] up
stuff under barek they would always give
their captives a trial they won't kill a
man unless something's prove it against
him but stone heart will hang anyone who
she deems guilty Thoris loses his belief
that what they're doing is just he loses
his belief in himself calling himself a
pink pretender a bad priest and a worse
wizard he sees the Brotherhood his
Brotherhood deteriorate from something
noble and righteous and holy to
something crueler and darker he says
that war makes monsters of us all so
where can Thor's go from here maybe
Thoris could just leave kind of like the
Hound did the popular gravedigger theory
suggests that Sandor Clegane is not dead
but living a life of peace and atonement
as a monk on the quiet Isle
maybe Thoris could do something similar
maybe go back to a red temple in Essos
and atone for his mistakes alternatively
he could try to finish what he started
maybe try to put the Brotherhood back on
a righteous path by killing Lady
Stoneheart Thoris after all is a fire
priest with a flaming sword and the
undead in this story generally of
honorable to fire trying to kill stone
heart might risk therosis life but he
might think it's worth the sacrifice
Thoris tells Brienne that it does not
matter how a man but
but only how he ends sacrificing himself
to kill Stoneheart could make a great
ending for Thoreau's a dramatic act of
selflessness by a formerly selfish man
so it could go a bunch of ways but the
point is that Thoreau's is a really
fascinating character someone who
transforms from a drunken warrior to a
righteous priest to a man again filled
with doubts about what he's become it'll
be great to see how his story ends the
books he might even turn up again in the
show we'll have to wait and see it's not
clear if the show will include the whole
stone heart thing by the way this
artwork of stone heart was created by
attached alternates you might like to
check out his deviantART for more anyway
hope you enjoyed this video many thanks
to all supporters on patreon including
reverend's Andrea mr. fee for essay
Cameron Weiss Vanya dog Michael Appel
Jason Rattray eric bakker ischium teeny
akash Partha Sarathi fancy Am's karen
grants from penguin hagen mark Raymond
team is Louise's Guillaume legend rudely
/ xxx night execute X X X mechanically
tamiya Freya danke salute Podrick
Targaryen lorenzo 89 angelica Saunderson
brad smoly Dali Jamaal Greg and Bob
thank you again and see you next time
you